[Music]
you know rural blacks was going to be
the original name of gym class heroes
either have more kids and they can't
feed their kids now
um
if they can't feed their kids now why
are they getting pregnant
or they're going to try and do it to
themselves they'll order this crazy
medicine on the internet and get these
pills to say it'll do it but it doesn't
we're already seeing patients like that
already
um because they can't oh my god i am i
just had an idea
anyone want to get into the selling fake
abortion pills business
well now we can't because you said it
out loud
delete the episode are we going to be
selling sugar pills
yeah just sell like little i'm not
getting those sugar pills i don't want
them to get fat either sell like little
like folic acid pills
like well something your body just needs
anyway and just mark it as [ __ ] baby
killing pills and just
[ __ ]
print money
and also when you're like well we can't
do it
what can't we do it's just fraud it's a
minor charge it's not like we're going
to go to prison for life it's not like
we're selling real baby killing pills
that would be illegal no or you get
government funding um it's like
guys it's it's like when somebody sells
fake drugs right they can't cops can
ever get you on the drugs
they get you on selling a fake drug
which is a way lesser charge it's like
uh
from the wire he's like man i'll do the
three ain't no thing
[Laughter]
[ __ ] maury levy comes in uh my client
did not actually possess any narcotics
he simply wanted to defraud these people
out of thirty thousand dollars
sorry what's your idea tc brand
abortion pills
okay look listen to me all right
i don't mind that if we actually get
paid
look i'm telling you i'm telling them um
what uh what we have been saying we will
not go back
and we will not back down
man first off you're too afraid to own a
gun and you're weaker than me what are
you gonna do
see that's your problem ladies if maybe
you if most of these [ __ ] are afraid
of guns maybe we're like i got a gun bro
come and take you know what i mean but
you're not you're also afraid of guns i
ain't free to you what are you gonna do
to me what are you gonna do to me
huh
we are gonna take this fight to every
single state what does that mean
take this fight are you
are i'm sorry is she encouraging
violence or some sort of female
insurrection
and let people understand what is it
right
rotc sections
i feel like we're getting a little away
from my original plan see virgin much
more so here's a problem here
really cheap [ __ ] like little
multivitamins and we sell them as a baby
killing pills we've every woman that
wants to kill her baby we're stealing
money from them that's beautiful right
there we get rich by the time anybody
figures this [ __ ] out we move to russia
but i hear you buy a yacht and make sure
we don't park it in the united states i
hear the i hear what you're saying the
here's the issue here marsh mercy you
have a great product the problem is
virgie and frozen are trying to
brainstorm a really good marketing idea
because you we need a name right like
that's all great but you also need a
cool name so i like i like that i like
the bay be gone baby
bay be gone what about
whoops a baby
i like whoops a baby okay it has to be
fun he's good i also like oops it has to
be fun right this will be a fun little
name
but think about it all the people
that and by the way mctiny has a good
point in the chat folic acid was perfect
marsh because pregnant women need lots
of gas
so i just randomly picked prenatal just
give prenatals give them prenatals
that's hilarious sell prenatal vitamins
and go yeah this will kill your baby and
i have a commercial so you know how
head-on has he applied directly to your
forehead
ours would be like apply directly to
your [ __ ] apply directly to your [ __ ]
oh my god could you imagine making
adding insult to injury not only selling
abortion pills that don't work but
selling them pills the prenatal vitamins
you'll be hilarious prenatal vitamins
you start giving
and it'd be [ __ ] so good oh [ __ ] dude
and by the way merch let's go even
better
when you give it to them you go here's
the thing though it's gonna work but you
can't also you can't drink for nine
months either for these to work
yeah you can't you can't let them that
way they can't they won't drink and
smoke either bro could you but could you
admit like
probably end up having to do a couple
years in jail right but how many lives
will we have saved we'll probably have
to pay like this is what they always do
with guys like that we have to pay back
some of the money yes and then we would
stash some of the money offshore do a
couple years in jail come out and we
come out the right wing the evangelicals
we're [ __ ] heroes we're like dinesh
d'souza level where they're like all
right he he did a crime but
these guys are heroes it's a really good
point right where you're like all right
technically it's a league like you know
like you're exactly like it did julian
assange you know or edward federal
prison i could do that like laying on my
[ __ ] head yeah
edward snowden edward [ __ ] snowden
yeah he did come technically did come in
a crime
but he's a hero to me right the stuff he
exposed was [ __ ] nuts dude i could
get so much crazy evangelical [ __ ]
after that
get out of jail and they're just gonna
be like oh my god you saved soulmate
like all those like mega mills like you
saved so many babies and i'm like you
know that's a good money that's a good
point if you use all the money and
someone said in the chat if you use all
your money on all the money on cocaine
they can't even take that from you no
go to jail that's it
and deal with it right and then you then
you know what then you get out you'll be
touted as a hero and you'll get like a
job being like an america one america
network you know correspondent
yes i mean i'm telling you you this is
this is a fail upward scheme this is a
beautiful thing it really is this is how
most people get to be part of the elite
i'm telling you dude this already sounds
better than the [ __ ] ocean's eight
movie by the way can i say that right
now we already have a better plan
because we're not trying to steal
sparkly dress or whatever they were
doing
yeah you know what i mean like [ __ ] come
on man
uh
but i like how they got the [ __ ] for
that one it really did just [ __ ] it
was like okay it's not like a lot of
people need a [ __ ] chinese acrobat
from movies i'll take it and then you
have to play heist music yeah of course
you gotta do stuff like this so so that
so that then there's different camera
shots of of them like frozen asian with
a bunch of asian women packing the pills
in boxes you know what i mean
it's
frozen smoking a cigarette just
screaming at them yeah frozen's gonna be
the like the chinese sweatshop foreman
that's yelling at them you know
that's way too many way too many
russell's got a sign behind him that
says work will make you free
and then all you see is merc dressing in
our armani suit walking in with a
business meeting to get marketing for
the product
yeah pulling up in a [ __ ] like brand
new [ __ ] like super car by the way
that you bought with the phony
corporation that we started yeah
just pulling up in one of those cars
that sounds like seven cars
oh [ __ ] man
that would be damn you got a lotus
i'm in dc juicing the fda you know what
i mean
just taking them to titty bars exactly
it's be like hey get him another round
actually we might we need to flip jobs
because i'm more of the knights oh
that's a good point fine
i'll go to the restaurant i'll go to the
restaurant i'll go to the restaurant
making sure the pills are and i'll be
the one going to titty bars doing
cocaine with all these fda guys and i'll
be at the four seasons with the [ __ ]
marketing guy trying to oh i love this
let's do it man i really like that asian
dancer yeah i'll have her sent out to
your room okay by the way here's your
room card 207 four seasons by the way
really by the way by the way
then you move then you have pessy the
accountant sitting there with those
accountant hats going
just [ __ ] laundering money
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean just giant
bags of cash oh [ __ ]
i mean i've been driving around leasing
a bulletproof hummer
oh [ __ ]
i love this this is great you can do
this
oh my god yes apps this is perfect
trenton wade's standing in front of one
of those steel doors that has the slot
exactly
yeah let him in trent
oh
this by the way ladies for those of you
that maybe just saw the title and came
in and be mad at us this is how we're
this is how seriously we're taking this
yeah
sorry were you guys still mad yeah
ladies i'm sorry look i know we don't
seem to be taking this very seriously
but we're only taking it as seriously as
you took you know the lives of children
you know we're goofing we're goofing
around about ripping off [ __ ] but
you're the ones that actually didn't
take the sanctity of life seriously bro
this is this so you go all you women
today can suck my dick and i mean no
seriously suck my dick because i'm not
coming in any of you that's for sure